efectivamente la pandemia ha empeorado
la situación de violencia hacia las
mujeres y la región latinoamericana como
siempre es una de las más afectadas
mientras por ejemplo en 2017 en europa
se registraba en 3.000 homicidios en
américa latina fueron 8.000 es decir 1.6
en cada 100 mil mujeres latinoamericano
y 0.7 de 100.000 europeas esto era en un
contexto antes previo a la pandemia con
la pandemia esto ha incrementado ha
empeorado en los primeros meses de
cuarentena de marzo a junio de 2020 se
registraron 1400 y eso de minicipios en
tan solo 19 países de américa latina los
países con mayores índices de
feminicidios en estos meses fueron
brasil méxico colombia argentina y
honduras es que cuando hablamos de
feminicidios sabes que nos referimos
específicamente a homicidios cuya causa
a homicidios de mujeres cuya causa está
vinculada a su condición de género
los datos concretos de incremento de
violencia porque sabemos que los
feminicidios son la expresión más
extrema de la violencia hacia las
mujeres
pero los datos de denuncias de violencia
pueden no reflejar la realidad concreta
de estos países porque las condiciones
de confinamiento hacen que muchas de las
mujeres víctimas tenga que estar
encerrada con sus victimarios y las
coloca en una situación más difícil para
denunciar los casos los casos de
violencia y recibir también la atención
necesaria que son uno de los principales
problemas que se han enfrentado para
lidiar con la violencia hacia las
mujeres durante la pandemia pero un
informe que realizó el programa de las
naciones unidas para el desarrollo
recopiló datos mensuales de denuncias de
violencia a través de las líneas de
ayuda en argentina brasil colombia
república dominicana méxico paraguay
y perú y la situación ha sido
precisamente que ha incrementado
considerablemente la denuncia en estos
países con relación al 2019 si natalia
le quiero preguntar cuáles son los focos
rojos de la violencia contra la mujer es
decir o sea la violencia más común que
utilizan contra las mujeres
bueno definitivamente el feminicidio
como te comentaba ya es la expresión
última de esta violencia hacia las
mujeres el confinamiento ha contribuido
a que uno de los elementos de las
expresiones de la violencia que es el
distanciamiento de las mujeres de todas
sus redes de apoyo se haya incrementado
también pero hay un tema del que se
habla poco en este contexto y son los
derechos sexuales y reproductivos
durante la pandemia
ha sido más difícil acceder a
anticonceptivos
y la pastilla del día después
ya tenemos en américa latina países como
honduras en la en donde la pastilla
anticonceptiva de emergencia está
totalmente prohibida también